Having completed a thorough analysis,
it's important to effectively
communicate the results to
the appropriate decision makers.
The type of presentation, and
visualizations used, should be
determined based upon both the audience,
as well as the analysis itself.
It's important to not just show up and
throw up, meaning that showing up
with positive data analysis is not the
best way to communicate your findings.
In general, the best practice is
to tell a story about the data
that meets the needs of
the decision makers.
Sometimes, especially with more
complex analyses, you may want to walk
the audience through the analytical
problem solving process used to perform
the analysis, emphasising the decisions
and assumptions you made along the way.
For complex data,
visualizations are very helpful in
identifying trends in your data.
For example, you may show a map to
illustrate that the electricity demands
vary by state,
as much as they do by temperature.
Also, it's always very important to
reference the data sources you used.
And finally, you can measure
the success of your analysis,
if it supports the decisions
that need to be made.
So there are the six steps to
the problem-solving framework.
We'll be using this
throughout the course,
to solve many different
business problems.